>> Larry: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
I LIKE, "LARRY, LARRY!"
YEAH.
THANK YOU, WELCOME TO "THE
NIGHTLY SHOW."
I'M YOUR HOST, LARRY, LARRY.
OKAY, NOW, WHO'S PUMPED FOR
SUPER BOWL SUNDAY?
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
HERE YOU GO.
HERE'S MY SUPER BOWL PREDICTION.
GOING OUT ON A LIMB, GOING OUT
ON A LIMB.
HERE'S MY PREDICTION EYE WILL BE
DRUNK BY THE COIN TOSS.
( CHEERS )
JUST SAYING.
WAKE ME UP FOR KATY PERRY,
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
( LAUGHTER )
ALL RIGHT, NOW, THIS HAS BEEN A
ROUGH YEAR FOR THE NFL WITH ALL
THEIR OFF-THE-FIELD SCANDAL, SO
IT'S GOT TO BE A RELIEF FOR FANS
OUT THERE TO FINALLY HAVE THE
SCANDAL ON THE FIELD.
>> THE SO-CALLED DEFLATE-GATE
SCANDAL.
>> THE NFL IS INVESTIGATING
ALLEGATIONS THAT 11 OF THE 12
FOOTBALLS THAT THE PATRIOTS USED
IN THEIR A.F.C. CHAMPIONSHIP WIN
OVER THE INDIANAPOLIS COLTS WERE
UNDER-INFLATED.
THAT WOULD BE AN ADVANTAGE SINCE
UNDER-INFLATED FOOTBALLS ARE
EASIER TO GRIP AND CATCH.
>> Larry: OKAY, ALL RIGHT,
NOW, I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE
EXPECTING ME TO DO A GRATUITOUS
BALL JOKE HERE, AND AS TEMPTING
AS IT IS, YOU KNOW, FRANKLY,
THAT'S ALL I'VE BEEN HEARING FOR
THE PAST WEEK.
I REALLY DON'T WANT TO TRAFFIC
IN THAT.
SO THAT'S WHY I ASKED MIKE YARD
AND RICKY VELEZ TO DO IT.
ALRIGHT GUYS, YOU HAVE 30 ON THE
BALL CLOCK.
OKAY, GET TO IT.
>> WHAT DO TOM BRADY'S BALLS AND
FEDERAL RESERVE HAVE IN COMMON.
>> WHAT'S THAT, RICKY?
>> THEY BOTH FEAR INFLATION.
>> WHY DID TOM BRADY GO TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN?
>> WHY?
>> HE GOT REJECTED FROM BALL
STATE.
>> A PRIEST, RABBI, AND TWO
DEFLATED BALLS WALK INTO A BAR.
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THE PRIEST FONDLED THE
DEFLATED BALLS.
>> WHAT'S THE WORST JOB IN
SPORTS?
>> SUCKING THE AIR OUT OF TOM
BRADY'S BALLS.
>> WHAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT
COULD COME BETWEEN TOM BRADY'S
DEFLATED BALLS AND THE SUPER
BOWL CHAMPIONSHIP?
>> WHAT'S THAT
>> THE GIANTS, TWICE.
>> HEY, RICKY, MY BALLS ARE SO
BIG.
>> HOW BIG ARE THEY?
>> THEY'RE JUST BIG, MAN.
>> Larry: OKAY, THAT'S ENOUGH,
THAT'S ENOUGH.
GREAT JOB, GUYS.
GIVE THEM A NICE ROUND OF
APPLAUSE.
( CHEERS )
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
SO HOW DID THE MAN AT THE CENTER
OF DEFLATE-GATE HANDLE THIS?
MR. BUNDCHEN?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
I MEAN-- I-- I-- I HAVE NO
EXPLANATION FOR IT.
>> Larry: I DO.
YOU CHEATED.
OKAY?
( APPLAUSE )
JUST LIKE WHEN YOUR TEAM GOT
CAUGHT IN 2007 ILLEGALLY SPYING
ON OTHER TEAMS.
THAT'S NOT BAD, THOUGH.
I MEAN, YOU WENT SEVEN WHOLE
YEARS WITHOUT A CHEATING
SCANDAL.
( LAUGHTER )
FOR THE PATRIOTS, THAT'S A
PRETTY GOOD RUN.
NOT BAD.
BUT, ANYHOW, BACK TO BRADY'S
NON-VIGOROUS DENIAL.
>> IS TOM BRADY A CHEATER?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
>> Larry: WAIT.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE TOM BRADY,
RIGHT?
YOU KNOW THEY'RE ASKING YOU THAT
QUESTION, RIGHT?
BECAUSE YOU SAID, "I DON'T
BELIEVE SO."
AS IF YOU'VE NEVER MET YOURSELF.
( LAUGHTER )
AND YOU SHOULD MEET YOURSELF.
YOU HAVE A VERY HOT WIFE.
( APPLAUSE )
NOW, IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE HE'S
LYING-- WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
PLAY THAT FOR ME ONE MORE TIME.
>> IS TOM BRADY A CHEATER?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
I MEAN, I FEEL LIKE I'VE ALWAYS
PLAYED WITHIN THE RULES.
>> Larry: OKAY, GUYS, LET, ALL
RIGHT, THIS IS NOT LYING, ALL
RIGHT.
WE HAVE SOMETHING ELSE HERE.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO BREAK THIS
DOWN FOR YOU IN A WHOLE
DIFFERENT WAY.
YOU KNOW THIS SHOW IS ALL ABOUT
TELLING THE TRUTH OR AS WE
CALL IT, KEEPING IT 100.
( APPLAUSE )
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW, BUT WHAT'S WEIRD ABOUT
BRADY IS THAT THIS DOESN'T FEEL
LIKE A LIE BUT IT DEFINITELY
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THE TRUTH.
HE'S KEEPING IT 70.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
NOW I KNOW THIS IS NEW, BUT STAY
WITH ME.
KEEPING IT AT 70 IS WHERE YOU
MEAN WHAT YOU SAY BUT YOU DON'T
SAY WHAT YOU MEAN.
OKAY?
RIGHT?
SO WHEN HE SAYS, "I DON'T
BELIEVE SO," HE MEANS BECAUSE I
KNOW SO.
RIGHT?
( LAUGHTER )
AND WHEN HE SAYS, "I FEEL LIKE
I'VE PLAYED WITHIN THE RULES,"
HE'S LEAVING OUT, "THAT I SET
FOR MYSELF."
OKAY?
OKAY.
NOW, TO HELP YOU BETTER
UNDERSTAND KEEPING IT 70, LET ME
SHOW YOU WHAT AN ATHLETE KEEPING
IT 100 LOOKS LIKE.
>> I'M THE BEST CORNER IN THE
GAME.
THAT'S THE RESULT YOU'RE GOING
TO GET.
DON'T YOU EVER TALK ABOUT ME!
>> Larry: SEE, SEE?
THAT'S 100, RIGHT?
I MEAN, DO YOU KNOW HOW SCARED
AMERICA WAS FOR THAT WHITE
WOMAN?
OH, MY GOD.
WHOO!
PEOPLE AREN'T USED TO ATHLETES
BEING 100.
IT IS THE OPPOSITE OF MAKING US
COMFORTABLE.
OKAY?
SO KEEPING IT 70 IS THE NFL'S
JAM.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE WASHINGTON
REDSKINS, A TEAM WITH PERHAPS
THE MOST OFFENSIVE SPORTS
NICKNAME SINCE THE OLD 1880s
BASEBALL TEAM GO HOME YOU SMELLY
IRISH QUIMSTICKS.
GO, FIGHTING QUIMSTICKS.
WELL, REDSKINS TEAM OWNER DAN
SNYDER DOESN'T WANT TO CHANGE
HIS TEAM'S SUPER RACIST NAME.
>> WHAT IS A REDSKIN?
>> A REDSKIN IS A FOOTBALL
PLAYER.
A REDSKIN IS OUR FAN.
THE WASHINGTON REDSKINS FAN BASE
REPRESENTS HONOR, RESPECTS
PRIDE, HOPEFULLY WINNING.
>> Larry: DAN, DAN, WHEN YOU
KEEP IT 70 LIKE THIS, THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS.
♪ ♪ ♪
HAPPY NOW, DAN SNYDER?
KEEPING IT 70 GOES FURTHER THAN
THE NFL.
TIGER WOODS WAS SURPRISING HIS
SKIING LADY FRIEND LINDSEY VONN
ON THE SLOPES WHEN HE APPARENTLY
HAD AN ACCIDENT.
>> TIGER WOODS TALKED ABOUT THE
BIZARRE ACCIDENT THAT RESULTED
IN HIM LOSING A TOOTH.
>> AND THE DUDE WITH ONE OF THE
VIDEO CAMERAS ON HIS SHOULDER
KNEELING IN FRONT OF ME, STOOD
UP, TURNED, AND CAUGHT ME SQUARE
IN THE MOUTH.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Larry: OKAY, HERE'S THE
PROBLEM, SEE, TIGER KEEPS IT 70
SO MUCH, EVEN WHEN HE MIGHT BE
KEEPING IT 100, I DON'T KNOW IF
I CAN TRUST HIM.
HE'S LIKE THE BOY WHO CRIED
70.
AND I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO
FEELS THAT WAY.
>> TIGER STICKING TO HIS STORY
DESPITE THE FACT RACE ORGANIZERS
TOLD THE PRESS NO OFFICIAL
REPORTS WERE FILED AND, "THERE
WAS NO SUCH INCIDENT."
>> Larry: A TOOTH?
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH TRUST HAS
TO BE LOST FOR US NOT TO BELIEVE
YOU ABOUT A TOOTH?
WHERE'S THE TOOTH, TIGER?
TELL ME WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
DAMN TOOTH!
OKAY, LOOK, ANOTHER ONE, NOW
LET'S TAKE LANCE ARMSTRONG.
NOW, REMEMBER HE LIED ABOUT THE
WHOLE STEROID THING, THEN HE
FINALLY GOT CAUGHT, RIGHT?
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID RECENTLY.
>> IT WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
MISTAKES OF MY LIFE.
I'D PROBABLY DO IT AGAIN.
>> Larry: NO, NO, NO, NO.
LANCE ARMSTRONG KEPT IT ZERO HIS
WHOLE CAREER, AND NOW HE'S
TRYING TO CRANK IT UP TO 100?
EVEN ON STEROIDS, YOU CAN'T GO
FROM 0 TO 100 THAT FAST.
WE'RE JUST NOT GOING TO BELIEVE
ANYTHING YOU SAY.
IRONICALLY, IF HE HAD JUST
CRUISED AT 70 THE WHOLE TIME,
HE'D PROBABLY STILL BE RACING.
BUT THEN TO BE SO CAVALIER
SAYING HE'D DO IT AGAIN, THAT
TAKES A LOT OF BALL.
( APPLAUSE )
COME ON.
COME ON, GUYS!
SERIOUSLY!
I HAD TO MAKE ONE BALL JOKE.
OOPS, DID IT AGAIN!
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.